if the world is getting too hot why not
give it some shade that's the simple
idea behind solar geoengineering a
radical response to global warming which
could rapidly halt rising temperatures
you reduce those peak temperatures that
are very destructive
but is it too good to be true it would
be like living underneath a hundred ton
boulder ready to fall at any time
as the debate heats up how does the
world decide if this technology is a
risk worth taking
[Music]
like many indigenous groups
the sami people are on the front line of
climate change
and it's also larson blind's job
to stand up for their way of life
the traditional livelihoods like
reindeer herding have survived through
industrialization and modern society
development and land encroachments and
we are still here but when people talk
about the future of climate change it's
not a future we are already dealing with
it and coping with it all seasons all
year round but the sami council is
concerned that one area of scientific
research aiming to counter climate
change could backfire on the world
the council is worried about the impact
of a controversial but potentially
life-changing technology known as solar
geoengineering
think of volcanic eruptions sulfur
dioxide released into the atmosphere
creates particles which reflect sunlight
back into space and cool the earth
scientists have suggested it may be
possible to reduce global warming by
using high-flying aircraft to release
particles into the stratosphere
bouncing the sun's rays back in the same
way
in 2021 scientists from harvard
university
researching solar geoengineering planned
a test flyer balloon from a nearby space
center over territory where the sami
live
esri testing area is in the mountain
area
so this is the area where the testing
would have taken place
although the first balloon wouldn't have
released any particles a complaint from
the sami council ensured it didn't take
off and helped persuade sweden's space
agency to cancel the project
the sami council objects to the message
this research project sends out about
climate change
like many it worries that a successful
technology could discourage the urgent
need to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
the notion of a plan b the notion of
technology saving us might put a pause
on the needed climate action
if the fossil fuel industry leans back
just a little and say well we'll wait
and see a bit
just that notion might be the thing that
makes us not reach the paris agreement
and that would be devastating
but models suggest that current
political action is insufficient to
limit global warming to the paris
agreement's target of 1.5 degrees
centigrade
so what about the case for doing at
least more research into solar
geoengineering
david keith is one of the scientists in
charge of the harvard project
he argues the risks from solar
geoengineering must be weighed against
the chance it could save millions from
heat waves but basically your
temperature noise is too big
a sami council are entirely within their
rights to make a statement which
effectively says that this whole line of
research is unethical and a bad idea my
views is a point of view with its own
ethical implications because the
benefits of solar geometry would most be
felt by poor people in hot countries
because you'd reduce those peak
temperatures that are very destructive
like most geoengineering researchers
professor keith doesn't believe the idea
should be a substitute for cutting
emissions
i think there's a certain kind of
monomedia that we can only talk about
one thing
i just don't think that's ethical or
good public policy of course we have to
cut emissions but that can't be all that
climate policy comprises
he argues that stifling research into
solar geoengineering now
could increase the risk of negative
consequences in the future
what blocking research does is it means
that when the decisions about deployment
come onto the agenda whenever that is
people will make that with less
knowledge about the side effects less
knowledge of how to do this in a way
that might be more effective and
probably with less serious discussion
about how to govern it
some studies have suggested that solar
geoengineering deployed equitably could
provide climate benefits to all
countries
but without global cooperation a
technology designed to cool the climate
could instead stoke international
conflict
because solar geo engineering could
disrupt rainfall patterns
and increase droughts some countries may
lose out
[Laughter]
what happens if you dim the sun by
geoengineering and remove solar energy
from the surface scientists such as
raymond pierre humbert believe a
technology aimed at countering one
global problem could create others
by ramping up disputes and sparking new
ones
what if russia likes an ice-free arctic
uh and wants less solar geo engineering
but what if india is laboring under
killer heat waves so often that they
really want to chill their climate down
anything that increases the level of
international tension in a world where
nuclear arms are already proliferating
is going to be a threat multiplier
some also fear being locked into solar
geo-engineering without any reverse gear
if humans fail to reduce emissions and
rely on solar geoengineering alone it
could mean having to do it forever in
the worst case scenario stopping it
abruptly could bring a disastrous
termination shock
the word is terror if anything forces
the solar geo engineering to stop we're
hit with catastrophic warming it would
be like living underneath a hundred ton
boulder just perched over your head
ready to fall at any time some
scientists advocating research into
solar geoengineering argue that
termination shock could be avoided by
gradually winding it down over decades
but we're thinking less globally and
more locally about solar geoengineering
helped to balance some of the risks
associated with it
[Music]
on the great barrier reef a group of
scientists led by oceanographer daniel
harrison are doing just that
[Music]
they're testing a kind of solar
geoengineering called marine cloud
brightening
the first time it has been tried
outside of a laboratory
cloud brightening is one of the ideas
that if it scales up how we hope that it
may it is potentially usable over the
entire reef and can help all of the
coral and all of the ecosystem
[Music]
using a custom design turbine with 320
nozzles
they release a cloud of trillions of
nano sized sea water droplets above the
ocean
if the droplets can reach the clouds
above the theory goes that they will
make them more reflective
what we're really interested in looking
at is the behavior of that plume of sea
salt droplets as it drifts away from the
boat
[Music]
we have a big focus on using drones or
sampling platforms to measure the plume
not just in a horizontal dimension but
also in a vertical dimension
if it works
the cooling effect could protect the
reef from bleaching
damage done to the coral during heat
waves
dr harrison's vision for marine cloud
brightening is targeted and temporary
rather than an attempt to alter the
climate on a larger scale
one of the great advantages of the cloud
brightening concept applied regionally
is that in the very low chance that
there were some unexpected or
undesirable consequences
you could stop producing the sea salt
spray and everything would go back to
normal after only a few days
[Music]
yet other proponents of solar
geoengineering research
argue that if cloud brightening were
used more widely
regional and unequal benefits could
become a problem
my only concern is that that this will
kind of be a thin end of the wedge that
allows geo-engineering technology that's
inherently quite patchy and therefore
unequal therefore more likely if used at
scale to actually make some people worse
off
arguments look set to intensify about
the balance of risks and rewards of
solar geoengineering as well as whether
and how it could be deployed equitably
it's the kind of debate that is all too
familiar when parts of the scientific
community
press the case for progress
in any disputed area of science it's
entirely legitimate for different civil
society groups to raise objections it's
a job of governments and democracies to
ask a bunch of questions and make an
overall decision in the public interest
[Music]
hi i'm catherine mariek environment
editor for the economist if you'd like
to learn more about this topic click on
the link opposite and if you'd like to
watch more of our now and next series
click on the other link thank you for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
you